This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. On a hot summer morning, worshipers gather at the first Baptist Church in Washington, DC. They've come in their Sunday best, shop suits and flowing skirts, shine dress shoes, and spiky high heels. They've come to be among friends and family, to pray and sing and rejoice after a long and hectic week. If you've taken part in a religious service at a church or another house of worship, have you ever stopped to think about how it all came to be? How did people become believers?
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在一个炎热的夏日早晨，信徒们聚集在华盛顿特区的第一浸信会教堂。他们穿着节日盛装，笔挺的西装和飘逸的长裙，擦得发亮的皮鞋，以及细长的高跟鞋。他们来到这里与亲友相聚，在经历了漫长而忙碌的一周后，祈祷、歌唱并欢庆。如果你曾参与过教堂或其他礼拜场所的宗教仪式，你是否曾停下来思考这一切是如何形成的？人们是如何成为信徒的？
Where did the rituals come from? And most of all, what purpose does it also? Amehruja! When we ask these questions, we most often look to history or theology for answers. But some social scientists are asking if we can better understand religion through the lens of human behavior.
这些仪式从何而来？最重要的是，它们有什么用处？阿梅胡加！当我们提出这些问题时，最常从历史或神学中寻找答案。但一些社会科学家在追问，我们是否能通过人类行为的视角来更好地理解宗教。
If people behave in particular ways when exposed to different religious cues, can reuse this information to work backwards and understand how those religious practices came about in the first place. Can the rise and fall of different religions tell us something about the needs of societies and how those needs change over time? Today we're going to take an in-depth look at these provocative ideas through the work of a Zim Sharif, a psychology professor at the University of British Columbia. He studies religion not from the point of view of faith or spirituality,
如果人们在接触到不同的宗教暗示时会表现出特定的行为，我们能否利用这些信息来进行逆向推导，从而理解这些宗教习俗最初是如何产生的？不同宗教的兴衰能否告诉我们社会的需求是什么，以及这些需求是如何随时间改变的？今天，我们将通过英属哥伦比亚大学心理学教授阿齐姆·沙里夫（Azeem Sharif）的研究，深入探讨这些具有启发性的观点。他研究宗教不是从信仰或灵性的角度出发，
but from a psychological perspective. He argues that human societies changed in a fundamental way several thousand years ago and this required a new psychological innovation. So for the vast, vast history of our species, we didn't live in large groups. We lived in very small groups, groups about 50 people, groups that never really got larger than 150. And the reason for that is because from a genetic standpoint, we're only built to be able to cooperate
而是从心理学的视角。他认为，几千年前人类社会发生了根本性的变化，这需要一种新的心理创新。对于我们这个物种极其漫长的历史而言，我们并非生活在大群体中。我们生活在非常小的群体中，大约50人左右的群体，规模从未真正超过150人。其原因在于，从遗传学的角度来看，我们天生只具备与我们能够熟练了解的人进行合作的能力。
with as many people as we can know well. So when you start having anonymous strangers and groups, when you start having people who's reputation you're unfamiliar with, what that means is that people can free-ride on the group, they can cheat on the group with impunity. And when you start having large groups of free-riders and cheaters in a group, it can't sustain itself. You need a level of cooperation between the people in a group for it to act and to work harmoniously. And so it was only in the last 12,000 years that we started getting groups that bubbled up from beyond 150 people to a thousand, 10,000 people. And what that means is that it needed something more than just our genetic inheritance.
因此，当你的群体中开始出现匿名的陌生人，当你开始接触那些你对其声誉不熟悉的人时，这就意味着人们可以在群体中“搭便车”，他们可以毫无顾忌地欺骗群体。当群体中开始出现大量搭便车者和骗子时，这个群体就无法维持自身的存在。一个群体要和谐地行动和运作，其成员之间需要达到一定程度的合作。因此，直到过去1,2000年里，我们的群体规模才开始从150人突破到一千人、一万人。这意味着它所需要的不仅仅是我们的基因遗传。
It needed a cultural idea. I needed a cultural innovation to allow us to succeed in these larger groups. And so one of the things that me and my colleagues have been arguing is that religion was one of these cultural innovations. And not just religion in general, it was one specific aspect of religion, the idea of a supernatural punisher, also known as God. It's a concept we will return to over and over again this hour,
它需要一种文化理念。我需要一种文化创新，来让我们在这些更大的群体中取得成功。我和我的同事们一直在争论的观点之一，就是宗教正是这些文化创新之一。而且不仅仅是泛指宗教，而是宗教的一个特定方面——超自然惩罚者的概念，也就是我们所知道的神。这是我们在本期节目中会反复探讨的一个概念，
basically, if early humans could be convinced that a God was going to punish them if they didn't act in line with the interests of the group, well, they would start to cooperate. And we see really interesting examples of this. So large trade networks that have existed in North Africa, where you have people who have no way that they can know each other, they're from opposite ends of an entire continent, and yet simply because they have a common religion in this case Islam, they can trust that the other person is going to be a reliable trading partner. And so just knowing that other people are God-fearing believers is sufficient
基本上，如果能让早期人类相信，如果他们的行为不符合群体的利益，神就会惩罚他们，那么他们就会开始合作。我们看到了这方面非常有趣的例子。例如，北非曾经存在的大型贸易网络，那里的人们完全没有途径了解彼此，他们来自整个大陆的截然相反的两端，然而，仅仅因为他们拥有共同的宗教——在这种情况下是伊斯兰教，他们就可以确信对方会是一个可靠的贸易伙伴。因此，仅仅知道其他人是敬畏神的信徒，就已经足够
to act as a Quf trust. So how does this clinical view of religion square with the way most believers think about faith? Allah, Waqmah, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu, wa-duhu the day to remember God. Throughout this episode we're going to have religious scholars and practitioners talk about their experience of faith. Here's Islamic scholar Akbar Ahmed on the Muslim call to prayer. The call to prayer in Arabic is very simple. It simply is Allah Akbar Allah Akbar Allah Akbar Hayal al salah Hayal al salah Hayal al F haya ala falah. It's simply saying, God is great, God is great, God is great, God is great. Come to prayer, come to prayer. Then it repeats, come to welfare, to what is good for you,
充当信任的信号。那么，这种对宗教的理性客观视角，与大多数信徒对信仰的看法如何契合呢？真主至大，万物非主，唯有真主，唯有真主，唯有真主……这是铭记真主的时刻。在这一整集节目中，我们将邀请宗教学者和修行者来谈谈他们对信仰的体验。以下是伊斯兰学者阿克巴·艾哈迈德（Akbar Ahmed）对穆斯林宣礼的看法。阿拉伯语的宣礼非常简单。它就是：真主至大，真主至大，真主至大，真主至大。快来礼拜，快来礼拜，快来成功，快来成功。它就是在说，真主伟大，真主伟大，真主伟大，真主伟大。来礼拜吧，来礼拜吧。然后它重复道：来获取福祉，去做对你有益的事，
come to what is good for you, and then ends by saying, again, Allahok, Barallahu akbar. So in a sense, it's a very simple call to put aside the daily tedium, the daily tensions and problems and it can be very therapeutic. Hayar al-salaam. Azeem Sharif hears the Muslim call to prayer very differently. He hears it as a researcher. He cites evidence from psychology and anthropology to show that religious practices like the Muslim
去做对你有益的事，最后以再次重复“真主至大，真主至大”结束。因此从某种意义上说，这是一个非常简单的召唤，让人放下日常的沉闷、日常的紧张和问题，这可以非常具有疗愈作用。快来礼拜。阿齐姆·沙里夫对穆斯林宣礼的理解则完全不同。他以研究者的身份来聆听。他引用心理学和人类学的证据表明，诸如穆斯林
call to prayer have measurable effects on human behavior. These studies are taking advantage of existing naturalistic cues of religion that are all around people when they're living in the Muslim world. This is the most salient reminder of religion in Muslim majority countries. And so a couple of studies have used that as the cue. One of them looked at cheating behavior. And what they found is that when the, the, the, the call to prayer is, is audible. People are much less likely to cheat.
宣礼这样的宗教习俗对人类行为有着可测量的影响。这些研究利用了穆斯林世界人们生活中无处不在的现有自然宗教暗示。这是穆斯林多数国家中最突出的宗教提醒。因此，有几项研究将其作为暗示。其中一项研究调查了作弊行为。他们发现，当宣礼声可以听到时，人们作弊的可能性要低得多。
In another study, researcher Eric Duham gave money to shopkeepers in Morocco and told him they could either keep the money for themselves or donate it to charity. And he recorded how much they gave during regular parts of the day and how much they gave when the call to prayer was going off and the results were remarkable. So first of all the shopkeepers were generally quite generous and they were generally quite charitable but when the call to prayer was audible everybody gave all the money to charity. It's the most remarkably consistent finding that I've seen. It was a remarkable effect that this audible cue of religion actually had on people.
在另一项研究中，研究人员埃里克·杜汉（Eric Duham）将钱给摩洛哥的店主，并告诉他们可以把钱留给自己，或者捐给慈善机构。他记录了他们在一天中的常规时间捐了多少钱，以及在宣礼声响起时捐了多少钱，结果令人瞩目。首先，店主们通常都相当慷慨，他们也通常相当乐善好施，但当宣礼声响起时，所有人都把所有的钱都捐给了慈善机构。这是我见过最显著、最一致的发现。宗教的这种声音暗示对人们产生了非同寻常的影响。
Azeem's point is not that religion always has positive effects on people. He's saying it's possible to study the effects of religious practices on human behavior just like you can study the effect of financial incentives or education. By measuring which religious practices change how people behave and which don't, you can start to understand the roles that different religions have played in different societies. Take a look at this now classic study from the Princeton Theological Seminary in 1973. Two researchers tested the effect of religious cues on helpfulness. Surely, students training to be pastors would lend someone a hand, right? It's known as the Good Samaritan study and it's based on a famous parable from the Bible. In the story,
阿齐姆的观点并不是说宗教总是对人产生积极的影响。他是说，研究宗教习俗对人类行为的影响是可能的，就像研究财务激励或教育的影响一样。通过衡量哪些宗教习俗改变了人们的行为，哪些没有，你就可以开始理解不同宗教在不同社会中所扮演的角色。来看一看1973年普林斯顿神学院这项现已成为经典的的研究。两名研究人员测试了宗教暗示对助人行为的影响。理所当然地，正在接受牧师培训的学生会向某人伸出援手，对吗？这就是著名的“好撒玛利亚人”研究，它基于圣经中的一个著名寓言。在这个故事中，
a traveler is robbed, beaten, and left for dead along the side of a road. Two people walk by and do nothing to help. And then finally, someone stops, a Samaritan. It's a tale that's been told and retooled for centuries, lacking the sermon by Martin Luther King Jr. Finally, a man of another race came by. He got down from his beast, decided not to be compassionate by proxy, but he got down with him at menace at first aid and helped the man in need. Jesus ended up saying this was the good man, this was the great man. So the students were told a story of the Good Samaritan and then asked to go to another building to complete a task. But here's a sneaky part. Along the way, the researchers strategically placed a man, slumped over in an alleyway who looked like he needed some help.
一个旅行者在路边遭到抢劫、殴打，被丢等死。两个人路过，什么也没做就走开了。最后，有人停了下来，一个撒玛利亚人。这是一个讲述了几个世纪并不断被重新加工的故事，马丁·路德·金博士曾对此进行布道：最终，一个外族人走了过来。他从牲口上下来，决定不通过代理人来表现同情，而是亲自下马提供急救，帮助那个需要帮助的人。耶稣最后说，这是一个好人，这是一个伟大的人。因此，学生们听到了“好撒玛利亚人”的故事，然后被要求去另一栋建筑完成一项任务。但狡猾的部分来了。在路上，研究人员策略性地安排了一个人，他瘫倒在小巷里，看起来需要一些帮助。
Just like in the Bible story, they had heard a few minutes ago. Would they stop and lend him a hand? This study famously did not find any difference between the religious people and non-religious people. In fact, the only predictor of whether somebody would help or not was whether they were in a rush or not. So, if you were in a rush regardless of whether you were religious or non-religious, you wouldn't help. And if you were not in a rush, well then you would help regardless of these fundamental
就像他们几分钟前在圣经故事里听到的一样。他们会停下来伸出援手吗？这项著名的研究发现，宗教人士和非宗教人士之间没有任何区别。事实上，一个人是否会提供帮助的唯一预测指标是他们是否赶时间。因此，如果你在赶时间，无论你是宗教人士还是非宗教人士，你都不会提供帮助。如果你不赶时间，那么无论你对宗教信仰有着怎样根本性的
beliefs that you have about religiosity. So we've seen one example where a queue from religion changes how people behave, the Muslim call to prayer in Morocco, and another where it doesn't, the Good Samaritan study. So why does one queue make a difference while the other does not? Azim says a lot depends on the context. One important piece of context you might not consider, the kind of God being invoked. Consider the difference between depictions of God's who are angry.
信念，你都会提供帮助。所以我们看到了一个例子，宗教暗示改变了人们的行为，即摩洛哥的穆斯林宣礼；以及另一个没有改变行为的例子，即“好撒玛利亚人”研究。那么，为什么一个暗示会产生影响而另一个不会呢？阿齐姆说，这很大程度上取决于语境。你可能没有考虑到的一个重要语境背景是：被召唤的神的类型。考虑一下对愤怒之神的描绘之间的区别。
Those who will not live by the law Consider the difference between depictions of gods who are angry, and voices that are much less scary. And he's willing to forgive them, God. You run your own studies on cheating, and in one of them you wrote, how much you believe in God matters less than what kind of God you believe in. What did you mean? Well, so there we wanted to see whether believing in a punitive God versus believing in a forgiving God. So a forgiving God would be one that you see predominantly to be loving and comforting and forgiving, but not angry vengeful or punitive. Whether that makes a difference in terms of your likelihood to cheat. And the reason that
那些不按律法生活的人……考虑一下对愤怒之神的描绘与那些不那么吓人的声音之间的区别。而他愿意原谅他们，上帝。你自己对作弊进行了研究，你在其中一篇论文中写道：你对上帝的信仰程度，不如你相信的是什么类型的上帝重要。这是什么意思？嗯，所以在那里我们想要看看，相信一个惩罚性的上帝与相信一个宽容的上帝。一个宽容的上帝主要表现为慈爱、安慰和宽容，而不是愤怒、复仇或惩罚。这是否会在你作弊的可能性方面产生差异。而原因在于
significant is because there are theories which suggest that a punitive God has become so popular in religions because it's an effective stick to deter people from immoral behavior. And so in this study, we had students come in and do this math task where we made it very tempting for them to cheat. And we wanted to see who would cheat. But we also collected data on what their view of God was. So we had them fill out their belief that their God is represented by various adjectives. And some of these adjectives were loving, comforting, kind, forgiving, and others were angry, vengeful, punitive, wrathful. And we wanted to see whether
这之所以重要，是因为有一些理论表明，惩罚性的上帝在宗教中变得如此受欢迎，是因为它是阻止人们产生不道德行为的有效大棒。因此在这项研究中，我们让学生进来做这个数学任务，我们让他们非常想要作弊。我们想看看谁会作弊。但我们也收集了关于他们对上帝看法的 数据。所以我们让他们填写他们对上帝各种形容词的信仰程度。其中一些形容词是慈爱的、安慰的、善良的、宽容的，而另一些则是愤怒的、复仇的、惩罚的、暴怒的。我们想看看这
that made a difference. And indeed it did. We found that the people, the more you believed your God to be on the punitive side of that spectrum, the less likely you were to cheat, whereas the more you believed your God to be loving, the actually more likely you were to cheat. He loves his children and he's willing to forgive them. What you're suggesting in some ways is that people are behaving very rationally. If you believe in an angry, vengeful punitive God, and you believe that this God is gonna harm you
是否会产生影响。事实的确如此。我们发现，你越是相信你的上帝属于该光谱中惩罚性的一端，你作弊的可能性就越小；相反，你越是相信你的上帝是慈爱的，你作弊的可能性反而越大。他爱他的孩子，并且愿意原谅他们。你在某种程度上暗示的是，人们在非常理性地行事。如果你相信一个愤怒、复仇、惩罚性的上帝，并且你相信这个上帝会在你做了错事时伤害你，
if you do something wrong, it's perfectly rational for you to stick to the straight and narrow. Yeah, and I would argue that this, again, is, I think it's no accident why the most successful religions have been, and I mean successful in terms of just sheer numbers, the societies that have been able to grow largest with the religions that they believe in, have had this idea of supernatural punishment at their core. Because it is an
那么你循规蹈矩是完全理性的。是的，我认为这再次说明，我认为最成功的宗教之所以能成功，绝非偶然，这里的成功仅仅是指纯粹的数量而言，那些能够凭借他们信仰的宗教发展到最大规模的社会，其核心都有这种超自然惩罚的概念。因为这是一个
effective deterrent. It does compel people rationally to act in ways which will avoid the wrath of a punitive God who can punish you quite severely. So according to the scriptures, Hale is a place that literally exists. That's not a bad-dest doctrine, that's not a Bethadist doctrine, that's a doctrine of the Bible, it exists, friend. It was made therefore as a place of punishment, not a place to simply go to. Besides the psychological studies, Azim says there's evidence from history and anthropology
有效的威慑。它确实以理性方式迫使人们采取行动，以避免一个能够对你施以相当严厉惩罚的惩罚性上帝的愤怒。因此根据经文，地狱是一个真实存在的地方。这不是浸信会的教义，这不是美以美会的教义，这是圣经的教义，它确实存在，朋友。因此，它是作为一个惩罚的地方而被创造的，而不是一个随便去的地方。除了心理学研究之外，阿齐姆说，历史和人类学的证据
that suggests modern religions arose to solve problems related to trust and cooperation. All the world's major religions today arose at times when human societies were struggling with the challenges of size, complexity, or scarcity. Certain religious ideas that would be most effective at encouraging people to be pro-social, like this idea of a big, omniscient, punitive god, tend to crop up in those particular circumstances when cooperation is particularly necessary.
表明，现代宗教的兴起是为了解决与信任和合作相关的问题。当今世界的所有主要宗教都兴起于人类社会正在与规模、复杂性或稀缺性挑战作斗争的时期。那些最能有效鼓励人们具有亲社会性的特定宗教理念——比如这种关于一个巨大的、全知全能的惩罚性上帝的概念——往往会在那些特别需要合作的特定情况下涌现出来。
So if you look at Societies that were larger that is with more anonymous strangers. You tend to see these types of gods emerge more frequently in those Societies, but you also see them emerge more frequently in societies that faced say particularly acute resource in societies that faced, say, particularly acute resource scarcity issues. So, in a place where it's very, very important that you share water in trustworthy, equitable ways, you see these types of big omniscient punitive gods emerge there as well. And so, there is this, yes, this correlation as far as we can tell now, between the necessity of cooperation and the types of cultural innovation, the religious innovations that would be most effective at bringing it about.
因此，如果你看看那些规模更大、即拥有更多匿名陌生人的社会，你会发现这类神明在这些社会中出现得更频繁；但你也会发现，它们在那些面临例如特别严峻的资源稀缺问题的社会中出现得也更频繁。因此，在一个非常非常重要、需要你以值得信赖和公平的方式分享水资源的地方，这些类型的大型全知全能惩罚性神明也会在那里出现。所以，就我们目前所能了解的来看，合作的必要性与能够最有效实现合作的文化创新、宗教创新类型之间，确实存在着这种相关性。
What is the evidence that we have that in earlier societies that were much smaller, people didn't believe in these big gods or these gods that have these huge effects or these punitive gods? So, if you look both at the archaeological record, as well as modern hunter gatherer tribes, so modern tribes that still live in ways that were similar to how we lived prior to 12,000 years when there was the agricultural revolution, we started settling the large groups. Those types of small societies
我们有什么证据表明，在规模小得多的早期社会中，人们不相信这些大神，或者不相信这些具有巨大影响力的神，或是这些惩罚性的神？因此，如果你同时查看考古记录以及现代猎人采集部落——也就是那些生活方式仍然类似于12,000年前农业革命发生之前、我们开始定居形成大群体之前的生活方式的现代部落，就会发现那些小型社会
where you don't have those anonymous stranger challenges tend not to have these large punitive gods. Their gods tend to be smaller and weaker and less morally concerned. And so you tend to see that those large gods, the punitive gods only emerge when it's necessary to have that cooperation spread. And when you have these small societies,
由于没有那些匿名陌生人的挑战，往往没有这些大型惩罚性的神。他们的神往往更小、更弱，受到的道德约束也更少。因此你会发现，只有当有必要传播这种合作时，那些大型神、惩罚性的神才会出现。而当你拥有这些小型社会时，
you don't need that. Can you give me an example? So a lot of research has been done on these small tribes like the Hadza and where the gods are, they're more like trickster spirits. They're neither omniscient, nor are they punishing the types of immoral behavior that would be necessary to get rid of in order to be cooperative.
你就不需要那个。能给我举个例子吗？因此，人们对这些小部落（如哈扎人等）进行了大量研究，在这些部落中，神明更像是恶作剧精灵。他们既不是全知全能的，也不会惩罚那些为了实现合作而必须消除的不道德行为。
The gods are, again, small forest spirits or trickster spirits that don't have the power nor the punitive ability, nor the really concern for these moral issues. Now, of course, this view of religion comparing ancient hunter-gatherer tribes with modern societies or measuring which gods produce what behavior. This kind of thinking can seem completely upside down to you if you're a person of faith. If you're a believer, this is not the way you think about religion.
神明依然是小型森林精灵或恶作剧精灵，既没有力量，也没有惩罚能力，对这些道德问题也没有真正的关心。当然，这种将古代猎人采集部落与现代社会进行比较，或者衡量哪种神产生什么行为的宗教观点，如果你是一个有信仰的人，这种想法可能会让你觉得完全颠倒。如果你是一个信徒，这不是你思考宗教的方式。
Your faith is a source of meaning, guidance, comfort. It's a connection to something greater than yourself. Let's go back to Islamic scholar at Paramah. I know that at times when I'm sitting in the Muslim world, especially in the evening at Maghrib time, when you know there's that magical moment when the day has just died and the night has not quite begun and there's that twilight in the atmosphere and suddenly there's a complete hush for a few seconds and you hear the azan, the beautiful azan and it drifts and writers have said poets have said it's like a feather in flight.
你的信仰是意义、指导、安慰的源泉。它是与比你自己更伟大事物的连接。让我们回到伊斯兰学者帕拉马。我知道有时当我坐在穆斯林世界里，尤其是在傍晚昏礼时分，你知道那种神奇的时刻，白昼刚刚消逝，黑夜尚未完全降临，空气中弥漫着暮色，突然几秒钟内万籁俱寂，你听到宣礼声，那美妙的宣礼声飘荡着，作家们曾说，诗人们曾说，它就像飞行中的一根羽毛。
It just drifts on in the air almost as if it is weightless, in its beauty and it just undulates on and on. So in that sense, it is a beautiful part of the symphony of Islam itself. Hayal al-Falaah I'm wondering whether you ever get pushback from religious people who basically are angry that you are dissecting their faith in a way that says, I can study this as if it's an organism, a microscope. I can study when it flourishes, when it doesn't flourish, how it grows, why it grows in one context, doesn't grow in another context.
它只是在空中飘荡，几乎失重般的美丽，不断地起伏。所以从这个意义上说，它是伊斯兰教交响乐中优美的一部分。快来成功。我在想，你是否曾经遭到宗教人士的强烈反对，他们基本上对你剖析他们信仰的方式感到愤怒，因为你说我可以像研究一个有机体、通过显微镜一样来研究它。我可以研究它何时繁荣，何时不繁荣，它是如何生长的，为什么它在一个语境下生长，而在另一个语境下不生长。
And people say, I believe because this God is a real God, I believe because this God has a real effect in my life, you shouldn't be coming in and studying this as if it's a scientific project. So yes, there is pushback. There's pushback from both sides for different reasons. I get pushback for that precise reason. People who are people of faith believe their religions to be divinely inspired. And so when you're reaching for naturalistic explanations for religion, that leaves little room for the divine inspiration. The origins for the
人们会说，我相信是因为这个神是真正的神，我相信是因为这个神对我的生活有真实的影响，你不应该像进行科学项目一样介入并研究它。所以，是的，有反对意见。来自双方出于不同原因的反对。我正是因为这个原因而遭到反对。有信仰的人相信他们的宗教是神圣启示的产物。因此，当你为宗教寻找自然主义的解释时，这就为神圣启示留下了很少的空间。宗教的
religion become over-determined. You have both a naturalistic reason for why it exists, and you have a divine reason for why it exists, and you don't need both. And so if you're positing a naturalistic explanation, well then maybe it casts some doubt or threat on the divine inspiration explanation. And so that's a very, I think, legitimate pushback from their perspective. I also get pushback from people who have a bone to pick against religion. And the reason for that is because some of the research I do empirically demonstrates some of the positive effects that religion has.
起源变得过度决定了。你既有宗教存在的自然主义原因，也有它存在的神圣原因，而你并不需要两者都有。因此，如果你提出一种自然主义的解释，那么也许它会对神圣启示的解释投下一些怀疑或威胁。因此，我认为从他们的角度来看，这是一个非常合理的反对意见。我也遭到那些对宗教心怀不满的人的反对。原因在于，我所做的一些实证研究证明了宗教所产生的一些积极影响。
And if people have a bone to pick with religion, they tend not to like to admit that there's anything good about religion. And so I get hate mail from both sides. When we come back, we'll take a closer look at one of our Zeems' more controversial ideas. Given that different religions have risen and fallen over the centuries, can you study religion as of it or a living organism, subject to the rules of Darwinian natural selection? I think that the application of evolutionary theory as really revolutionized our understanding of the origins and functions of religion. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
如果人们对宗教心怀芥蒂，他们往往不愿意承认宗教有任何好的方面。因此我收到了来自双方的攻击信件。当我们回来时，我们将更仔细地探讨阿齐姆更具争议性的观点之一。鉴于不同的宗教在几个世纪中兴衰交替，你能把宗教当作一个受达尔文自然选择规律支配的生物或活有机体来研究吗？我认为进化论的应用确实彻底改变了我们对宗教起源和功能的理解。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Let's take a moment to go back in time. For the vast majority of human history, we lived in small groups of around 50 people. Everyone knew everybody. If you told a lie, stole someone's dinner or didn't defend the group against its enemies, there was no way to disappear into the crowd. Everyone knew you, and you would get punished. But in the last 12,000 years or so, human groups began to expand, from a few dozen to more than a thousand. And now it wasn't so easy to punish the cheaters and the free writers. So we needed something big, vast, and epic force that could see what everyone was doing and enforce the rules. Since individual people could no longer police gigantic groups, the policing
让我们花点时间回到过去。在人类历史的绝大部分时间里，我们都生活在大约50人的小群体中。每个人都认识所有人。如果你说谎、偷了别人的晚餐，或者没有保护群体免受敌人侵害，你是不可能在人群中隐身消失的。每个人都认识你，你也会受到惩罚。但在过去的12,000年左右，人类群体开始扩张，从几十人增加到一千多人。现在，要惩罚作骗子和搭便车者就不那么容易了。所以我们需要某种宏大、广阔且史诗般的力量，能够看到每个人在做什么并执行规则。既然个人再也无法监管庞大的群体，那么这种监管
had to be done by a force that was superhuman. That force, according to psychologist Azim Sharif, was a modern idea of a punitive god, the kind that many preachers warned can send you to hell. Hell is a place. It is a place that existed before you were ever born. It is there, it is going to be there, and there's nothing you can do to change that one bit. What so ever? Azim says the many religions we see around us today emerged in different societies at different times as mechanisms to solve problems of trust and cooperation.
就必须由一种超人的力量来完成。根据心理学家阿齐姆·沙里夫的说法，这种力量就是惩罚性神明的现代概念，也就是许多传教士警告会把你送进地狱的那种神。地狱是一个地方。它是一个在你出生之前就存在的地方。它就在那里，它将一直存在，你无能为力去改变哪怕一点点。无论如何？阿齐姆说，我们在周围看到的许多宗教，在不同的社会、不同的时期作为解决信任和合作问题的机制而出现。
I just am making a difference if the the churches today have stopped preaching on hell. If the preachers don't preach on hell, it is still a place that you must deal with one day. So the picture that you're painting from your Zeme is this really fascinating picture that religion has all these different effects on people. It has an effect on how we trust one another, how we're generous towards one another, sometimes we're generous when we're reminded of religiosity, when we're reminded of the divine.
如果今天的教堂停止宣讲地狱，我只是在产生影响。如果传教士不宣讲地狱，它仍然是你终有一天必须面对的地方。所以，阿齐姆，你描绘的这幅图景确实非常迷人：宗教对人有着所有这些不同的影响。它对我们如何彼此信任、如何彼此慷慨产生影响，有时当我们被提醒想起宗教信仰、被提醒想起神圣时，我们会变得慷慨。
It makes a difference whether the gods we believe in are benevolent gods or angry gods. It's also the case that maybe some religions flourish and thrive in a certain moment or in a certain ecosystem, but then whether and fail away in another ecosystem. And it seems to me all of these different things are pointing to the same fundamental theory, which is that you're looking at religion as an evolutionary phenomenon. You're just trying to understand how it can work in one context, how it can fail in other contexts, how you can study it almost as a living organism.
我们信仰的神是仁慈的神还是愤怒的神，也会产生不同的影响。同样的情况是，也许某些宗教在一个特定的时刻或生态系统中蓬勃发展、繁荣昌盛，但在另一个生态系统中却消亡了。在我看来，所有这些不同的事情都指向同一个基本理论，那就是你把宗教视为一种进化现象。你只是试图了解它如何在一种语境下发挥作用，如何在其他语境下失败，如何几乎像研究一个活生生的有机体一样去研究它。
Yes, I think that's exactly right. I think that the application of evolutionary theory has really revolutionized our understanding of the origins and functions of religion. Now in evolutionary theory, one of the most exciting developments is extending the Darwinian logic of selection of organisms based on how well they fit their environment, to cultural ideas as well, and cultural groups as well. And this is what's called cultural evolution, or cultural evolutionary theory. It's also called dual inheritance theory. And the reason it's called dual inheritance theories,
是的，我认为完全正确。我认为进化论的应用确实彻底改变了我们对宗教起源和功能的理解。在进化论中，最令人兴奋的进展之一是将基于生物对其环境适应程度的达尔文选择逻辑，扩展到文化理念以及文化群体中。这就是所谓的文化演化或文化进化理论。它也被称为双重继承理论。之所以被称为双重继承理论，
because unlike most other animals, humans come into the world with not just a genetic inheritance from their parents, but an entire line of cultural ideas that get passed down to them as well. And for about 100,000 years, we have been a necessarily cultural species. We have not been able to survive without the cultural knowledge that we inherit. And so a good example of this is fire. That's a cultural idea. If we
是因为与大多数其他动物不同，人类来到这个世界不仅带有来自父母的基因遗传，还带有整整一系列同样传承给他们的文化理念。在过去大约10,0000年里，我们一直是必然的文化物种。如果没有我们继承的文化知识，我们将无法生存。而这方面的一个好例子就是火。那是一个文化理念。如果
didn't have that, we will not be able to survive because our bodies are now adapted to needing able to survive because our bodies are now adapted to needing fire to pre-digest that is cook our food. And so the idea is that religion is one of these cultural ideas that similarly serves these functional roles in our lives and has done for at least 10,000 years. So what that means is that you can understand religions as they are to date. Today's major religions is bearing the legacy of thousands of years of trial and error and selection, so that what current religions are made up of, they're made up of those things because those served social functions in the past, they contributed to the societies that they were attached
我们没有这个，我们将无法生存，因为我们的身体现在已经适应了需要火来预消化（即烹饪我们的食物）。因此，这个想法是，宗教就是这些文化理念之一，它同样在我们的生活中发挥着这些功能性作用，并且已经持续了至少10,000年。这意味着你可以理解宗教在今天的面貌。当今的主要宗教承载着数千年试错和选择的遗产，因此现今宗教的组成部分之所以存在，是因为它们在过去服务于社会功能，它们促成了与其相连的社会的
to surviving. You can see these patterns in the historical record. For example, ancient humans worship gods who could prevent natural disasters. But as the needs of societies changed, their gods changed too. Let us pray. As people built cities and civilizations that were more resilient, new kinds of gods. Welcome to the prayer to do well in school. With different powers emerged, and the requests people made of them changed as well. Father, we decree and declare that as they prepare for school, for tests and exams,
生存。你可以在历史记录中看到这些模式。例如，古代人类崇拜能够防止自然灾害的神明。但随着社会需求的改变，他们的神明也随之改变。让我们祈祷。随着人们建立起更有韧性的城市和文明，新型的神明——欢迎来到为学业顺利而祈祷的时刻——带着不同的力量涌现出来，人们向他们提出的请求也随之改变。天父，我们颁布并宣告，当他们为学校、测试和考试做准备时，
show them what to study and how to study most effectively. Lord, please give them wisdom and understanding, as well as a job. A Zeeam's point is that local conditions, like individual ecosystems, can create conditions where certain beliefs flourish and where others fade away. If belief in a certain God helps a group to thrive, that religion is likely to spread. An evolutionary theory of religion can also explain why many religions are deeply, some might say obsessively, interested in questions related to sex. Number one warning sign, amorous glances.
请向他们展示该学什么以及如何最高效地学习。主啊，请赐予他们智慧和理解力，以及一份工作。阿齐姆的观点是，地方条件（如各个生态系统）可以创造出这样的条件：某些信仰蓬勃发展，而其他信仰则逐渐消退。如果对某个特定神明的信仰有助于一个群体繁荣发展，那么这种宗教就很有可能传播开来。宗教的进化论也可以解释为什么许多宗教都深深地——有人可能会说是痴迷地——关注与性相关的问题。头号危险信号，脉脉含情的目光。
You can hear these themes in religious broadcasts all the time. How much sex to have? Flortacious looks. Look at Proverbs 6 and 25 with me if you would. Whom to have sex with? It says, do not lust after her beauty in your heart. How to avoid certain kinds of sex. Nor let her allure you with her eyelids.
你随时都可以在宗教广播中听到这些主题。做爱多少次？挑逗的眼神。如果你愿意，请和我一起看看箴言第6章第25节。与谁发生性关系？它说，不要在心里贪恋她的美色。如何避免某些类型的性行为。也不要让她用眼睑勾引你。
And it makes sense from a Darwinian perspective. Sex is a battery production, and the organization of families and the growth of a population are integral to the long-term survival of societies. One of the things that's very common among religions is to have norms regulating what you could call family values. You should have a lot of kids.
从达尔文的视角来看，这说得通。性是为了繁衍后代，而家庭的组织和人口的增长对于社会的长期生存至关重要。宗教中非常普遍的一件事是拥有规范所谓家庭价值观的行为准则。你应该多生孩子。
Three, four, six, twelve. I mean, how many, is there a biblical mandate of how many we should have? Well, there is a biblical mandate, if you will, that says God bless them as it be fruitful and multiply. You should have homosexual relationships. I say it's wrong because that's what the scripture says. You shouldn't have that much birth control. If we look at the Bible tonight and examine this,
三个、四个、六个、十二个。我的意思是，到底生几个，有没有关于我们应该生几个的圣经圣谕？嗯，确实有一个圣经圣谕，可以说是上帝保佑他们要生养众多，遍满地面。你不应该有同性恋关系。我说这是错的，因为经文就是这么说的。你不应该使用那么多避孕措施。如果我们今晚看一下圣经并对此进行检验，
we'll see that this is actually not something that God wants us to do. Now, those also serve these culturally adaptive purposes, because they encourage people to produce lots of children, having lots of children leads to larger societies, larger societies can outcompete those societies that didn't have a lot of children. So if you had two religions, one, which said, have a lot of sex, make a lot of children, don't use birth control, another one that said never have sex, or if you do,
我们会发现这实际上并不是上帝希望我们做的事情。现在，这些也服务于这些文化适应的目的，因为它们鼓励人们生养许多孩子，生养许多孩子会导致更大的社会，更大的社会可以胜过那些没有很多孩子的社会。所以如果你有两个宗教，一个说，多做爱，多生孩子，不要用避孕措施；另一个说，永远不要做爱，或者如果你做了，
only use birth control. Which society, looking down one, two, three generations, is going to be better off? Well, the one that actually produced offspring, became a larger civilization, a civilization that was able to out-compete either in active warfare or just through taking the resources of the other society. It's a competition between cultural ideas and cultural groups, such that those socially functional ideas tend to be preserved over generations. And so this is how cultural evolution works. So if you buy the idea that religions arose at a certain point of time, that in some ways there are form of cultural evolution at a certain point of time, that in some ways there are form of cultural evolution, and certain types of religions and certain types of gods arose at certain points in time in order to converse certain kinds of cultural benefits and groups of people.
只使用避孕措施。那么，展望一两三代人之后，哪个社会会过得更好呢？嗯，那个真正繁衍后代、成为更大文明的社会，一个能够在积极战争中或者仅仅通过夺取另一个社会的资源而胜出的文明。这是文化理念和文化群体之间的竞争，因此那些具有社会功能的理念往往会在几代人的时间里被保留下来。这就是文化演化的运作方式。因此，如果你接受这样一种观点：宗教在某个时间点兴起，某种程度上它们在某个时间点是文化演化的一种形式，某种程度上它们是文化演化的一种形式，并且特定类型的宗教和特定类型的神明在特定的时间点兴起，以便为人们的群体转化某种文化福利。
One of the challenges, of course, is that if I'm a religious person and I now think of religion as being a marker of my willingness to trust the next person, who's also a religious person, there is an incentive for people to cheat. For people to say, I'm actually a religious person, I deeply believe in this God, when in fact, they don't, because they just want to take all the advantages that come from religious faith. And this brings us to the idea of rituals and the idea of costly rituals. Talk about this idea. Why would you have the development of costly rituals in some ways as a precondition to how religion ends up enforcing these cultural norms? So this is one of the really great examples of how evolutionary theory can inform our understanding of religion. Things that were previously mysterious about religion now make sense in an evolutionary perspective.
当然，其中一个挑战在于，如果我是一个有宗教信仰的人，现在我将宗教视为我愿意信任下一个同样有宗教信仰的人的标志，那么人们就会有作弊的动机。人们会说：“我其实是一个有宗教信仰的人，我深深地信仰这位神”，而事实上他们并非如此，因为他们只想获取宗教信仰带来的所有优势。这就把我们带到了仪式和代价高昂的仪式的概念上。谈谈这个概念。为什么在某种程度上，代价高昂的仪式的演化会成为宗教最终强制执行这些文化规范的前提条件？这正是进化论如何丰富我们对宗教理解的绝佳例子之一。以前关于宗教的神秘事物，现在从进化论的角度来看都说得通了。
So in evolution, there's this concept of costly signaling. That you have a hard-to-fake signal, which serves as a reliable cue of something you're trying to demonstrate. So the classic example of this is peacock feathers. The male peacock has this beautiful plumage, which is a sexual display. And the reason it's an effective sexual display is because only the healthiest peacocks can have the large plumage because of how costly it is to other aspects of the peacock's life. It can't fly very fast, it can't run away very much, it makes it very visible to other
所以在进化论中，有一个概念叫做代价高昂的信号。你拥有一个难以伪造的信号，它作为你试图证明的事物的可靠暗示。这方面的经典例子就是孔雀羽毛。雄孔雀拥有美丽的长羽，这是一种求偶展示。之所以它是一个有效的求偶展示，是因为只有最健康的孔雀才能长出这样的大羽毛，因为这对孔雀生命的其它方面代价高昂。它飞得不快，逃跑能力很差，这使得它对其他
predators. And so, if you're not the healthiest of peacocks and you try to fake this plumage, well, you're gonna get eaten. And so the female peens can use the display as a reliable indicator that, well, if I mate with this one, he actually has good genes because if he didn't have good genes, he would not be able to have this beautiful plumage. And so that might seem like an unrelated example, but if you look at the costly rituals that happen in religion,
捕食者非常显眼。因此，如果你不是最健康的孔雀却试图伪装这种羽毛，那么你就会被吃掉。因此，雌孔雀可以利用这种展示作为可靠的指标，即如果我与这只孔雀交配，它确实拥有好基因，因为如果它没有好基因，它就无法长出这美丽的长羽。所以这看起来可能是一个不相关的例子，但如果你看看宗教中发生的代价高昂的仪式，
those are indications to other people in your group that you are a true believer. You are showing in a costly way indications that you're a believer. It is hard to fake signal. If you weren't a costly way, indications that you're believer. It is a hard to fake signal. If you weren't a true believer, you wouldn't go through all that effort. Effort, like following the vows of chastity, poverty,
那些就是向你群体中的其他人表明你是真信徒的迹象。你以一种付出代价的方式展示了你是信徒的迹象。这是一个难以伪造的信号。如果你不是真信徒，你不会付出那么大的努力。比如遵守天主教的贞洁、贫穷
and obedience and Catholicism. We don't see them as restrictive. Rules, we see them as freeing. Keeping kosher and Judaism. When I eat, I know that I am a Jew. And wearing a veil or headscarf in Islam. I use it to identify myself. I use it to be a symbol of who I am. Now you have trustable cues, credibility,
和服从誓言的努力。我们不认为这些是限制性的规则，我们认为它们是令人解放的。犹太教中的保持洁食（Kosher）。当我进食时，我知道我是一个犹太人。以及伊斯兰教中佩戴面纱或头巾。我用它来标明自己的身份。我用它作为我是谁的象征。现在你有了可信任的暗示、人们真实宗教情操的可信度
enhancing displays of people's genuine religiosity, which indicates that you actually can trust them. I want to take a closer look at one of those rituals to underscore the difference between the way believers think about religious practices and a Zeeam's theory. Jainism, a small South Asian religion, has lots of rituals that ask for sacrifices, like fasting. Jainism is somewhat similar to Hinduism and Buddhism in that one of its core tenets
增强展示，这表明你确实可以信任他们。我想更仔细地考察其中一种仪式，以强调信徒对宗教习俗的看法与阿齐姆理论之间的区别。耆那教，一个南亚的小型宗教，有许多要求牺牲的仪式，比如斋戒。耆那教在某种程度上类似于印度教和佛教，其核心信条之一是
is non-violence. Jains are strict vegetarians, and each year, they observe a holiday called perutian. It's a week-long fast where practitioners limit their consumption of both food and water. We've come to a Jane Temple on the outskirts of Washington, DC. It's a bombing Friday morning and around 2,000 people have gathered to celebrate the last day of Perutian. The temple is actually a converted ranch-style house. The walls have been knocked down to make space for seating. The purpose of perution is to repent for one's sins over the past year.
非暴力。耆那教徒是严格的素食主义者，每年他们都会庆祝一个名为“帕如山”（Perutian）的节日。这是一个为期一周的斋戒，修行者在此期间限制食物和水的摄入。我们来到了位于华盛顿特区郊区的一座耆那教寺庙。这是一个阳光明媚的周五早晨，大约有2,000人聚集在一起庆祝“帕如山”的最后一天。这座寺庙实际上是一栋改建的牧场风格房屋。墙壁已被拆除，以为座位腾出空间。“帕如山”的目的是为一个人过去一年的罪过忏悔。
Kamlesha says these are seven days when he nourishes his soul rather than his body. I heard them the full of past. Upvas is a kind of fast. In upvas, you do not eat anything at all. The only nourishment is water, and that too has to be boiled first and then blessed. Many of the jains who have gathered at the temple have completed similar fast. Pallavisha says Perusian gives her a better perspective
坎姆勒沙说，这是他滋养灵魂而非滋养身体的七天。我听说它们充满了过去。Upvas 是一种斋戒。在 Upvas 期间，你什么都不吃。唯一的滋养是水，而且水也必须先煮沸并祈福。许多聚集在寺庙里的耆那教徒已经完成了类似的斋戒。帕拉维沙说，秘鲁之旅让她对
on the struggles that other people face in the world. Yes, I did three fasting, three days separate, you know, without water. And I believe in that because if I do fast, you know, without food, what is my body? I can feel that without food, we are nothing. So, you know, that way, you know, I can help other people when they are hungry. This willingness to go hungry for her faith also identifies Pallavi as a true believer. She's willing to make a sacrifice that others are not.
世界上其他人所面临的挣扎有了更好的看法。是的，我做了三次斋戒，三天分开的，你知道的，不喝水。我相信这一点，因为如果我斋戒，你知道，不吃东西，我的身体会怎样？我能感觉到，没有食物，我们什么都不是。所以，你知道，那样的话，你知道，当别人挨饿时，我可以帮助他们。她为了信仰而甘愿挨饿的意愿也表明帕拉维V是一个真正的信徒。她愿意做出别人不愿做出的牺牲。
Now, of course, most religious people who make such sacrifices don't see what they are doing as costly signaling. Pallavi isn't fasting in order to communicate to other jains that she's a trustworthy member of the group. She's saying, I'm a devout person. My religion calls on me to make the sacrifice. I asked a Zim about the difference between an evolutionary theory of rituals and how believers think about their behavior.
当然，现在大多数做出这种牺牲的宗教人士并不认为他们所做的是昂贵的信号传递。帕拉维斋戒并不是为了向其他耆那教徒传达她是这个群体中值得信赖的成员。她说，我是一个虔诚的人。我的宗教要求我做出牺牲。我问阿齐姆关于仪式的进化理论与信徒如何看待他们的行为之间的区别。
Again, I just want to clarify the difference between how people think in an individual way and sort of the effect that's has at a group level. So for example, let's say, religion commands you to take a very costly and difficult pilgrimage, for example, that involves maybe physical difficulties or financial difficulties. The people who are embarking on that pilgrimage are not thinking to themselves,
再次说明，我只是想澄清人们在个体层面的思考方式与这种思考在群体层面上产生的效果之间的区别。举个例子，比方说，宗教命令你去进行一次非常昂贵且艰难的朝圣之旅，例如，这可能涉及身体上的困难或财务上的困难。踏上那次朝圣之旅的人并没有在心里想，
what I'm doing is a costly signal to other members of my religion. They're saying I'm just a devout person, my religion calls on me to do this thing and that's why I'm doing it. So there's a difference between how this might work in some ways at a community level, at a society level and how the individual practitioner thinks about it, the individual practitioner, the individual peacock isn't thinking, let me grow beautiful feathers because that sends a costly signal. Yeah, so there's something that we can call functional opacity, that people are not aware of these ultimate reasons, the ultimate evolutionary reasons why they're engaging in this behavior. They're aware of what we could call the proximate reasons, the immediate reasons, what they believe,
我正在做的事是对我宗教中其他成员的一个昂贵信号。他们在说，我只是一个虔诚的人，我的宗教要求我做这件事，这就是我做这件事的原因。所以，这在某种程度上在社区层面、社会层面如何运作，与个体实践者如何看待它之间存在着区别，个体实践者，个体孔雀并没有在想，让我长出美丽的羽毛吧，因为这会发送一个昂贵的信号。是的，所以有一种我们可以称之为功能不透明性的东西，人们并没有意识到这些终极原因，即他们参与这种行为的终极进化原因。他们知道我们可以称之为近因、直接原因的事情，即他们所相信的，
the reason they're doing it for. They're doing it because they're God asks them to do it. But really, the reason that there is a belief that God would ask you to do that, the reason why that belief exists in the first place is because it serves that functional purpose. And so they're enacting rituals that serve larger, hidden purposes that are very functional for their societies, but to them, it's just what their religion tells them to do. You know, I came by two interesting studies recently, one of them by Nicholas Hobson, and he found, along with other colleagues, that novel rituals, even when they're completely meaningless, you ask a group of people to perform that novel rituals, even when they're completely meaningless, you ask a group of people to perform a novel ritual,
他们这样做的原因。他们这样做是因为他们的上帝要求他们这样做。但实际上，之所以存在上帝会要求你这样做的信念，之所以这种信念首先存在，是因为它服务于这种功能目的。因此，他们正在颁布服务于更大、隐藏目的的仪式，这些目的对他们的社会非常有用，但对他们来说，这只是他们的宗教告诉他们要做的事情。你知道，我最近看到了两项有趣的研究，其中一项是由尼古拉斯·霍布森进行的，他与其他同事发现，新颖的仪式，即使它们完全没有意义，你让一群人去执行这些新颖的仪式，即使它们完全没有意义，你让一群人去执行一个新颖的仪式，
it has the power to increase trust among fellow members who are performing this novel ritual. The other study was by Panacheotus Mitkides, and he showed, along with his colleagues, that extreme rituals often had a big effect on promoting moral behavior, not among the performers of the ritual, but on observers. Yeah, so one of the leaders in this type of extreme ritual research is this anthropologist Dmitry Sigilates,
它有能力增强执行这种新月仪式的同伴之间的信任。另一项研究是由帕纳乔图斯·米特基德斯进行的，他和他的同事表明，极端仪式往往对促进道德行为产生巨大影响，这种影响不是在仪式的执行者中，而是在旁观者中。是的，所以这类极端仪式研究的领导者之一是人类学家德米特里·西吉拉特斯，
who's done this really interesting research on firewalkers. And what you find is that when you have observers watching people undergoing these rituals, their actual heartbeats synchronize with the people engaging in the rituals, and the more you have that synchronization, the more they feel like they're part of a group. And so you ask, well, why did fire walking emerge? Why did circumcision emerge?
他对走火者进行了非常有趣的研究。你发现，当有旁观者看着人们经历这些仪式时，他们实际的心跳会与参与仪式的人同步，这种同步性越强，他们就越觉得自已是群体的一部分。所以你会问，那么，走火是怎么出现的呢？割礼是怎么出现的呢？
Why did any of these painful rituals, there's many, many more examples of really terribly painful rituals? Why did they emerge? It's not random. The ones that we have, the ones that have been preserved exist because they have this impact on our psychology
为什么会有任何这些痛苦的仪式，还有很多很多非常痛苦的仪式的例子？它们是怎么出现的？这不是随机的。我们所拥有的那些，被保留下来的那些存在是因为它们对我们的心理有这种影响
that allow groups to cohere around each other, that allow this communication between members of the group that encourage trust between them. So another example is this work on what's called synchrony, which is just engaging in actions at the same pace and the same rhythm as others. And you have this in terms of him singing, but you also have this in terms of marching that is often used in military drills for the same reason. When you're engaging in an action in rhythm with somebody else. That creates the psychological connection that makes people feel fused as a group. You can hear the power of synchrony in the chance of the word home.
使得群体能够彼此凝聚，使得群体成员之间的这种沟通成为可能，并鼓励他们之间的信任。因此，另一个例是对所谓同步性的研究，这只是以与他人相同的速度和节奏参与行动。你在合唱圣歌方面有这一点，但在军事演练中出于同样的原因经常使用的行进方面，你也有这一点。当你与其他人有节奏地参与一项行动时。这会产生心理联系，使人们觉得自己作为一个群体凝聚在一起。你可以在“欧姆”这个词的唱诵中听到同步的力量。
Here's Hinduism scholar Shobha Patak. It's a sacred syllable that seems to be created by adding three different Sanskrit letters together. The letter A, the letter U, and the letter M. It doesn't have a dictionary meaning, but it has a lot of connotations. And so, in early Hinduism, in texts like the Upanishads, philosophical texts, it is used to represent the reality that encompasses the entire universe. Often a text or a chant, a mantra, will start with the syllable Ome. And I think the reason why that is is not only does it have the significance of standing for a particular God in his totality or her totality, but you have this column of sound that gives you a sense of vastness. I think it's sort of similar to what happens when you have two singers singing at the exact
这里是印度教学者肖巴·帕塔克。这是一个神圣的音节，似乎是通过将三个不同的梵文字母加在一起创造出来的。字母 A，字母 U 和字母 M。它没有字典里的含义，但它有很多内涵。因此，在早期的印度教中，在诸如《奥义书》这样的哲学文本中，它被用来代表包含整个宇宙的现实。通常，一个文本或一个唱诵，一个咒语，会以音节“欧姆”开始。我认为原因不仅在于它具有代表一个特定的神在其整体或她的整体中的意义，而且你还有一列声音，它给你一种广阔感。我认为这有点类似于当你有两个歌手在完全相同的
same frequency. You start to have these beats in the room. With OOM, it creates something around you, I think, that makes you feel like you're part of something. Oh This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've looked at a theory that suggests that religions arose to solve problems of social cohesion. Psychologists as Zim Sharif makes the case that much like living organisms, religions have evolved over time with different gods and different fates arising and
相同频率下演唱时发生的情况。房间里开始出现这些节拍。有了“欧姆”，它会在你周围创造出某种东西，我认为，这会让你觉得自己是某样东西的一部分。哦，这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们探讨了一个理论，该理论认为宗教的兴起是为了解决社会凝聚力的问题。心理学家阿齐姆·谢里夫指出，就像生物一样，宗教随着时间的推移而进化，不同的神灵和不同的命运在几千年中兴起又
falling away over the millennia. A Zim makes the case that religions play a functional role in societies helping them run more smoothly and strengthening the bonds of trust. more smoothly and strengthening the bonds of trust. But of course, religions can also be the source of conflict and war. Religious violence is often in the headlines. set fire to an orphanage. It appears to show he's beheading at the hands of ISIS. Social scientists like Azim Sharif argue that a Darwinian view of religion doesn't just explain the way religion makes us more generous or helpful. It also explains how and why religions mobilize groups to violence.
消亡。阿齐姆指出，宗教在社会中发挥着功能性作用，帮助社会更顺畅地运行并加强信任纽带。更顺畅地运行并加强信任纽带。但当然，宗教也可能是冲突和战争的根源。宗教暴力经常成为头条新闻。放火焚烧孤儿院。这似乎显示他在伊斯兰国的掌权下被斩首。像阿齐姆·谢里夫这样的社会科学家认为，对宗教的达尔文主义观点不仅解释了宗教使我们更慷慨或更有帮助的方式，它还解释了宗教如何以及为什么动员群体走向暴力。
Religious forework can lead people into battle and prompt them to disregard their personal safety. Here's an example. In an earlier episode of Hidden Brain, we spoke to the anthropologist Scott Atron. He's drawn studies on capture Islamic state fighters near the Iraqi city of Kerkuk. So there's a front there, mud walls that extend for a thousand kilometers and about every kilometer there's a mud turret with about twenty fighters inside and that's where we were working. And we got a hold of some captured Islamic state fighters and we ran these experiments. What we found, and this is not just true for the Islamic State. This is true for people who are willing to sacrifice their lives and kill others at the same time across the board. And it's also true for movements that are peaceful, but where the people who are driving these movements are willing to shed their own blood.
宗教前沿工作可以将人们引向战斗，并促使他们忽视自己的人身安全。这里有一个例子。在“隐藏的大脑”早期的节目中，我们采访了人类学家斯科特·阿特兰。他进行了关于在伊拉克基尔库克市附近被俘的伊斯兰国武装分子的研究。所以那里有一条前线，绵延一千公里的泥墙，大约每公里有一个泥炮塔，里面大约有二十名战斗人员，这就是我们工作的地方。我们抓住了一些被俘的伊斯兰国武装分子，并进行了这些实验。我们发现的，这不仅适用于伊斯兰国。这也适用于那些愿意牺牲自己的生命并在同一时间杀死其他人的人，各行各业都是如此。这也适用于那些和平的运动，但推动这些运动的人愿意流血。
For example, the civil rights movement or movements like Gandhi's movement in India, they are committed to a set of values which are sacred. That means values which are immune to trade-offs. For example, you would not change your children or your religion, probably or your country for all the money in China. And when you have these kinds of values which you will not trade off, and which are not subject to the standard constraints of material life, things that occurred in the distant past, or in distant places that are sacred, are actually more important than things in the here and now. They're also oblivious to quantity. It doesn't matter if I kill one, or I attract one, or a thousand, thousand or no one as long as my intention is good and righteous.
例如，民权运动或印度的甘地运动等运动，他们致力于一套神圣的价值观。这意味着那些不受权衡取舍影响的价值观。例如，你可能不会为了全中国所有的钱而改变你的孩子或你的宗教，或者你的国家。当你拥有这种你不会进行权衡的价值观时，并且这些价值观不受物质生活标准限制的影响，那些发生在遥远过去或遥远地方的、神圣的事物，实际上比此时此地的事物更重要。它们也对数量视而不见。只要我的意图是善良和正直的，我杀死一个，或吸引一个，还是一千个、一万个或没有人，都无关紧要。
And once you lock into these values, they're immune to social pressures, they're not norms. That is, even if you're best friends, your family, your loved ones are against you, you will not see an exit strategy. You will not see an exit strategy. Scott Atron has found that religiously inspired Islamic state fighters are single-minded. They have only one identity and they will fight and die not just for that group but for every single individual in that group. And once this happens, we also have other measures which show they develop a sense of invincibility and actually perceive themselves, their own bodies, to be much bigger than they actually are, and they perceive the other group to be much weaker. Critics of religion sometimes point to such fanatical behavior and say, look, this is evidence that there's something wrong with religious faith.
一旦你锁定这些价值观，它们就不受社会压力的影响，它们不是规范。也就是说，即使你最好的朋友、你的家人、你所爱的人都反对你，你也看不到退路。你也看不到退路。斯科特·阿特兰发现，受宗教启发的伊斯兰国武装分子是头脑单一的。他们只有一个身份，他们不仅会为那个群体而战并献出生命，还会为该群体中的每一个个人而战。一旦发生这种情况，我们还有其他指标表明他们培养了一种无敌感，并且实际上认为自己，他们自己的身体，比实际要大得多，而他们认为另一个群体要弱得多。宗教的批评者有时会指出这种狂热的行为并说，看，这证明了宗教信仰出了问题。
Psychologist Azim Sharif says, such criticisms miss the point. So the first thing that needs to be said is that coalitional violence is very old in our species. It's something that we see shared with our closest cousins, the chimpanzees. And so it's something that does precede religion. But what religion adds to it, I think, is actually consistent with this evolutionary perspective, which is that we're going to engage in wars. The question is, does religion enhance your side's ability to triumph in those wars? And the thing that religion adds is more than any other factor I can think of aside from perhaps family, religion allows people to introduce sacred values. Things that people are willing
心理学家阿齐姆·谢里夫说，这种批评没有抓住重点。所以首先需要说明的是，在我们物种中，联盟暴力是非常古老的。这是我们与我们最近的表亲黑猩猩共同看到的事情。所以这是先于宗教存在的。但我认为，宗教对其增加的东西实际上与这种进化视角是一致的，那就是我们将要参与战争。问题是，宗教是否能增强你们这一方在那些战争中取胜的能力？而宗教所增加的东西，除了我能想到的任何其他因素（也许除了家庭之外）之外，宗教允许人们引入神圣的价值观。人们愿意为之奋斗的事物
to fight for beyond all utilitarian or rational calculus, allow is religion to make people better fighters. So yes, religion does contribute to our war like nature, but it does so in a very adaptive, culturally-adaptive way. Azim is not saying that religious violence is socially desirable. He's saying that natural selection doesn't really care about being socially desirable. On average, a religion that helps societies triumph in war is a religion that spreads. So, there are lots of examples when I look at modern societies today, where I see other institutions, other forces that in some ways offer competition to religion. When I think about what will cause
超越所有功利或理性计算的战斗，允许宗教使人们成为更好的战士。所以是的，宗教确实促成了我们好战的天性，但它以一种非常适应性的、文化适应性的方式做到这一点。阿齐姆并不是说宗教暴力在社会上是可取的。他是说自然选择其实不在乎是否在社会上可取。平均而言，一个帮助社会在战争中取胜的宗教就是一个传播的宗教。所以，当我审视当今现代社会时，有很多例子，我看到其他机构、其他力量在某些方面对宗教构成了竞争。当我思考是什么会导致
people to fight and die, you now no longer need religious faith, you can have nationalism, you can have patriotism, people willing to die for the flag. When it comes to trust, you know, you and I don't have to belong to the same religion anymore. We can both agree, you can sell a house to me and I can buy a house from you because we both believe that there are institutions organized by the state that will ensure that you will actually sell the house to me and I will actually give you money for it. I put my money in a bank every month and I actually only see a bunch of digits on a piece of paper, but I trust that the bank at some level is actually holding on to my money and I have absolutely no idea what religion the bankers belong to.
人们战斗和死亡时，你不再需要宗教信仰，你可以有民族主义，你可以有爱国主义，人们愿意为国旗死。当谈到信任时，你知道，你和我不再需要属于同一个宗教。我们都可以同意，你可以把房子卖给我，我也可以从你那里买房子，因为我们都相信，国家组织的机构会确保你真的把房子卖给我，而我会为此给你钱。我每个月把钱存进银行，实际上我只看到一张纸上的一堆数字，但我相信银行在某种程度上实际上在替我保管钱，而我完全不知道银行家属于什么宗教。
Are these all examples of how modern societies have come to essentially displace the need for religion? So yes, I think so. So in terms of these other isms that people are willing to fight and die for, it's important to know that the idea of sacred values extends beyond just religious values. There are non-religious things that we sacralize. So as soon as you sacralize something, it allows people to fight and die for it. So we have a fertile psychological meadow that's ready to sacralize things and you just have to find the right key to fit into that walk
这些都是现代社会如何基本上取代对宗教的需求的例子吗？所以是的，我认为是这样。因此，就人们愿意为之战斗和牺牲的其他主义而言，重要的是要知道，神圣价值观的概念不仅限于宗教价值观。有些非宗教的东西我们将其神圣化。因此，一旦你将某事神圣化，它就允许人们为之战斗和牺牲。所以我们有一片肥沃的心理草地，准备将事物神圣化，你只需要找到正确的钥匙来打开那扇门。
Religion is a great one it fits very well, but it's not the only thing that does so. Thank you. God bless you and God bless Please United States and America. We'll sacralize ideas like freedom. We'll sacralize our nation. Thank you God bless you and God bless America. We'll sacralize the flag To the flag of the United States of America And in terms of the governmental institutions that can spread trust One of the interesting things you see is that if you look across countries Those countries that report having the least importance of religion to their daily lives are the countries that have the highest faith in the rule of law. So those are the places where you trust the institutions like the bank
宗教是一个很好的选择，它非常契合，但它并不是唯一能做到这一点的东西。谢谢。上帝保佑你，上帝保佑请美利坚合众国。我们会将自由等理念神圣化。我们会将我们的国家神圣化。谢谢，上帝保佑你，上帝保佑美国。我们会将国旗神圣化，致美利坚合众国的国旗，就能够传播信任的政府机构而言，你所看到的有趣事情之一是，如果你跨国家观察那些报告称宗教对其日常生活重要性最低的国家，正是那些对法治拥有最高信念的国家。所以这些地方是你信任诸如银行之类的机构的地方
or contract enforcement or the police or the justice system. Once you can set up those types of trusted secular institutions, well that obviates the need for a lot of what religion has done. Now, it's only been in recent years that we've been able to have those types of centralized, effective institutions and still in most parts of the world are not able to. But in those places where we are, we see ourselves moving towards a post-religious world, where a lot of the functions of religion are accomplished by other means and potentially better means. Azeem thinks that if regulations and good governance provide the trust and cooperation that religious
或合同执行或警察或司法系统。一旦你能够建立起这些类型的受信赖的世俗机构，这就会消除对宗教所做的大部分事情的需求。现在，直到近年来我们才能够拥有这些类型的集中、高效的机构，而且世界上大多数地方仍然无法做到。但在那些我们能够做到的地方，我们看到自己正在走向一个后宗教时代，在那里，宗教的许多功能是通过其他手段来实现的，而且可能是更好的手段。阿齐姆认为，如果法规和良好的治理提供了宗教
bonds once provided, new kinds of faith might flourish. Religions that don't have an angry God who threatens to punish you if you step out of line. Religions that don't talk a lot about hell and damnation but instead spend more time on building community, offering services like cooking classes or singles nights or childcare. Especially in places where you had other structures that were allowing for people to act in these harmonious cooperative ways, say secular institutions of law, under that umbrella where religion no longer has to shoulder the burden of of enforcing cooperation, you can
纽带曾经提供的信任和合作，新的信仰可能会蓬勃发展。那些没有一个愤怒的上帝、威胁如果你越界就要惩罚你的宗教。那些不常谈论地狱和惩罚，而是花更多时间建立社区、提供烹饪班、单身之夜或托儿服务等服务的宗教。特别是如果你在其他结构能够让人们以这些和谐合作的方式行事的地区，比如世俗的法律机构，在那个保护伞下，宗教不再需要承担强制合作的负担，你可以
have religions start tilting in the other direction more towards the religious benevolence and away from the religious malevolence, which is no longer as necessary for that religion. So a good example of this is Jehovah's Witnesses. And this is actually where some of these theories came from. I had Jehovah's Witnesses who would visit me when I was living in Vancouver. They'd visit me quite frequently because the first time they visited my roommate was bacon cookies and she offered them cookies and so they kept coming back and I was fascinated by the conversations we had because one of them they had their little watchtower magazine
让宗教开始向另一个方向倾斜，更多地走向宗教慈善，远离宗教恶意，因为该宗教不再那么需要恶意。所以一个很好的例子就是耶和华见证人。这实际上也是其中一些理论的来源。当我住在温哥华时，有耶和华见证人来看望我。他们相当频繁地来看望我，因为他们第一次访问我的室友时做了培根饼干，她给他们饼干，所以他们一直回来，我对我们进行的对话着迷，因为他们有一个小瞭望塔杂志
and it said, do we believe in hell on the cover and then you have to open it up and read that they didn't. And Jehovah's Witnesses, that's a relatively new religion, a relatively new sect of Christianity and one that emerged under this umbrella of an existing secular society. It emerged in the United States when the United States had laws that ensured that people would follow the rules. I have to ask you, have you ever been religious yourself? I was raised religious. I was raised Muslim, but I wandered away from the faith as a teenager. And I would consider myself a secular atheist now. I'm wondering if you're ever at family gatherings or even family gatherings that are inspired by
封面上写着“我们相信地狱吗”，然后你得打开它阅读，他们不相信。耶和华见证人是一个相对年轻的宗教，是基督教的一个相对年轻的宗派，它在现有世俗社会的保护伞下出现。它出现在美国，当时美国有确保人们遵守规则的法律。我不得不问你，你自己曾经信仰过宗教吗？我是在宗教环境中长大的。我是在穆斯林家庭长大的，但在青少年时期我背离了信仰。我现在认为自己是一个世俗无神论者。我想知道你是否曾经在家庭聚会中，甚至是由某种宗教场合引发的家庭聚会中，人们觉得你在评判他们、研究他们、分析他们，就像科学家在显微镜下研究微生物那样，你基本上是在说，我理解你为什么这样做，因为这有一个自然主义的解释。对于一个深信宗教的人来说，对于那些宗教在情感上意义重大的人来说，当有人出现并说，看，这对你来说是不透明的，但你所相信的背后有一个深刻而隐藏的进化原因，这可能是一件相当痛苦的事情。我想他们会生你的气的。
some kind of religious occasion, where people feel that you are judging them and studying them and analyzing them, the way that a scientist would study microbes under a microscope, that you're basically saying, I understand why you do this, because there's a naturalistic explanation for this. And for someone who is deeply religious, for whom religion means a great deal emotionally, there is something probably quite painful about having someone come along and say, look, this is opaque to you, but there is a deep and hidden evolutionary reason why you believe what you believe. They're going to be upset at you, I would think.
是的，我确实还有很多有宗教信仰的家人。这些年来，在研究这个主题的过程中，我学到的是，你要有所选择地进行争论。你不需要对此进行对抗。人们从宗教中受益匪浅。人们也从宗教中遭受了很多痛苦，但当你知道一个非常亲近的人是有宗教信仰的，他们可能正经历生活中的挣扎、疾病，
Yeah, so I do have a lot of religious families still. And I've learned over the years that I've been studying this topic that you pick your battles. You don't need to be confrontational about this. People benefit a lot from religion. People suffer a lot from religion as well, but you can see when you know somebody very closely who is religious, often who's potentially going through struggles in their life illnesses,
无论如何，他们都从宗教中受益。因此，我觉得没有必要通过挑战来明确威胁那些对他们有很大益处的东西。我认为亲近我的人知道我对宗教的立场，但我并不觉得有必要表现出敌意。结果，我认为我们也许达成了一种某种不安的和平。
whatever, that they benefit from the religion. And so I don't feel the need to explicitly threaten what is benefiting them quite a bit by challenging it. I think that people who are close to me know my position on religion, but I don't feel the need to be antagonistic about it. And as a result, I think we reach maybe some sort of uneasy piece.
阿齐姆，谢谢你今天加入“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢邀请我。阿齐姆·谢里夫是英属哥伦比亚大学的心理学教授。这期“隐藏的大脑”由劳拉·夸雷利、露西·珀金斯、帕茨·查、珍妮·施密特和雷娜·科恩制作。我们的团队包括塔拉·博伊尔、托马斯·刘和阿迪蒂亚·班德·莱穆迪。特别感谢公共广播节目“不同信仰的声音”允许我们使用他们的音频肖像。
Azeem, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Azim Sharif is a psychology professor at the University of British Columbia. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Laura Quarelle, Lucy Perkins, Parts Cha, Jenny Schmidt and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Thomas Liu and Aditya Band Lemudi. Special thanks to the public radio show Interfaith Voices for allowing us to use their audio portraits.
它们来自一个关于神圣声音的系列，叫做“信仰的声音景观”。我们本周的无名英雄是迈克·查普林斯基，他是 NPR 的技术支持之神。在我们为这期节目做最后的润色时，我们的编辑软件崩溃了，这是 NPR 从未见过的崩溃方式。迈克修复了它并拯救了局面。谢谢迈克。要了解更多“隐藏的大脑”内容，你可以在脸书和推特上关注我们。如果你喜欢这个节目，请与朋友分享。并不是每个人都知道如何订阅播客。如果你认识需要帮助的人，请向他们展示
They're from a series on sacred sound called the Soundscapes of Faith. Our unsung hero this week is Mike Chaplinzki, a tech support god here at NPR. As we were putting the finishing touches on this episode, our editing software crashed in a way that no one at NPR had seen before. Mike fixed it and saved the day. Thanks Mike. For more hidden brain you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like the show please share it with a friend. Not everyone knows how to subscribe to a podcast. If you know someone who needs help please show
他们如何订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是 NPR。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
them how they can subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
呁们如何订阅我们的节目。我是销卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是国家公共电台。这个节目暂无评论。点击文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。